je vis avec mes crises d'angoissé mais
enfin on va dire que maintenant j'arrive
allait enfin alors elles disparaissent
pas parce que moi pour moi les crises
d'angoissé disparaît pas ça disparaît
jamais mais on peut essayer de les
dompter de les comprendre et donc du
coup maintenant j'arrive je commence à
de mieux en mieux vivre avec alors
qu'avant c'était elle qui vivait pour
moi je pouvais rien faire
avec mon petit spot lumineux c'est super
génial et c'est parti et lorsque tu peux
que présenter m olala me présenter en
promenant mais quel plaisir
alors je m'appelle j'aime ça mais sur
les réseaux sociaux de nolito j'ai 28
ans et alors qu'est ce que je fais dans
la vie je vais le conte sur les réseaux
sociaux voilà je pense que ça va ça
résume bien le truc chez n'importe quoi
je fais des crashs ts des trucs
complètement ravagé un peu gênant et
malaise en défaut par moment et puis
voilà je pense que ça me représente bien
ah oui mais il faut quand même que je
présente pas mal
mais j'ai pas le téléphone ou la bagarre
qu'il faut quand même que je présente
pas mais là c'est beau mais regarde moi
ce cadre et on est où là alors là on est
fin il n'y a pas vraiment de lieu enfin
c'est pas vraiment non mais c'est une
forêt qui à côté du chemin une forêt
c'est des portions de forêt je pense
qu'on va aller là parce que deux côtés
on va faire tirer par des chasseurs je
pense à là c'est pas marqué interdit si
ils ont pas mis ce que je vois un petit
truc rouge mais non c'est bon ben palais
là alors du coup parce qu'en plus c'est
une montée je vais suez dollar est l'un
des films et je vais t'en sueur dans les
strongles mois passés par là en fait
j'ai tenté l'examen d'entrée à l'école
des avocats je peux à dire concours
parce que sinon je vais me faire
attaquer dans tous les sens c'est pas un
concours est gelée raté une fois c'est
raté deux fois et là je me suis dit bon
on va peut-être arrêter les conneries
donc que j'ai arrêté tout ça et je me
suis lancé sur les réseaux sociaux
bonjour
bonjour dit pas bonjour votre dos il a
perdu sa langue que je te foutrais ça au
four thermostat 5 on a élevé va pas de
couilles a du coup peut perdre la
campagne ah ouais en fait j'ai vécu a
faim depuis tout petit j'ai toujours été
dans la campagne moi je m'amusais avec
des je construisais des cannes à pêche
et j'allais dans les temps à côté de
chez moi georges était vraiment
quelqu'un de campagne après bombe en
avait déménagé en gironde avec ma mère
et j'ai fini à bordeaux pour mes études
à les deux une pasta party sec
on va y aller lui c'est facile c'est la
main au 8 août en carbone tout en carton
non tu sais qui c'est le manceau
sérieuse baisse et michael jackson kiss
& kill a ressuscité
et moi j'ai très mal vécu outre mes
crises d'angoissé j'ai très mal vécu je
n'aime pas la ville fin juin bien comme
ça un ou deux jours mais au bout d'un
moment fait il n'y a pas de tu te sens
pas libre tu te sens fermé on n'y a
aucune liberté là il ya juste des
oiseaux et c'est quoi qu'on les entend
pas trop la biche est si longtemps tu
paies voilà je préfère entendre ça que
des bruits de moto et une voiture assez
fatigant à force au crible pas de tqs
d'angoise à mes petites crises
d'angoissé elle qui sont là depuis
pousse ça fait combien de temps
maintenant je pense que ça fait dix ans
que plus de dix ans que je fais des
crises d'angoissé depuis le collège donc
disons que si j'en ai 28 le collège mais
ça fait plus de dix ans jusqu'à 18 ans
était déjà plus au collège donc
ça doit faire même quinze ans maintenant
que j'ai commencé à faire des crises d
angoisse
déjà déjà le collège ça pardonne pas
trop faim avec les gens qui critiquent
tout le temps moi du fait que c'était
efféminé dont je me fais attaquer tout
le temps et du coup je pense que c'est
ça qui a un peu mais permis de faire
ressortir les crises angoisse 3 c'est
elle qui me disaient pas de parler au
barreau ne pas prendre le tram tout ça
et maintenant je commence petit à petit
à reprendre une petite vie mais bon
elles sont toujours un peu présentement
à rival et les supporter 10 on et j'ai
commencé à en parler sur youtube
non j'ai dû en parler des différents
story on m'a dit ah oui tu fais des
crises d'angoissé on dirait pas je me
suis dit bon allez j'aime s'il est en
dedans par les enfants sur youtube parce
qu'il ya à dire tu traverses depuis des
années tu montres tous athées abonnés
mais tu parle pas de ça et c'est vrai
que ça m'a finalement dû bien moi d'en
parler et j'ai vu que l'on n'était pas
tout seul quand il y avait plein de
personnes qui faisait des crises
angoisses et après en fait j'ai
commencéà
après ça en parler normalement je vais
chez la psy aujourd'hui les gens me
disaient mais tu vas chez la psy tu le
dit a atteint pas honte c'est pas tabou
chez toi jean tu nous dis ça comme si tu
allais chercher une baguette de pain
mais c'est la vérité changeant rien rien
de choquant d'aller voir une cif ya
jamais eu un moment je me suis dit j'ai
honte je ne vais pas en parler pourquoi
les gens pensent que
parce que enfin en catégorie ça
directement dit que c'est allé voir un
psychologue c'est qu'on est complètement
taré c'est que vraiment faim on est
complètement phares allumés de la tête
mais pas du tout ma avoir une silhouette
on va bien voir un podologue pour ses
problèmes de pieds on va avoir une
psychologue pour ses problèmes au mental
enfin quand ça va pas enfin le mais je
pense que c'est tabou parce que si les
gens minimise les générations d'avant
nos parents ils vont dire oui c'est rien
ça va ça va passer il trouve pas pour
eux c'est pas important enfin il ya eu
pire dans leurs pas mais là olalala bon
pamela la boue l es tu te calmes et je
viens de le répéter tuées dans la ville
sur les résoudre je suis quand même fier
d'eux et je suis fier d'eux commencé à
m'en sortir de plus en plus des crises
angoisse je suis quand même fier de voir
que je bats j'arrive à faire des
interviews j'arrive à aller sur paris
vont pas tous les jours non plus de voir
que le monde est beau parce qu'il ya eu
un moment où j'ai commencé à me dire
qu'en fait c'étaient tous les gens
étaient mauvais que tout était négatif
j'ai commencé vraiment me ment font
d'armand fermer un parmi amis ma famille
je voyais personne et donc du coup c'est
vrai que
là de voir en fait que le monde est pas
si mauvais que ça il ya des choses il ya
des choses belles dans la vie
je suis fier voilà d'avoir avancé là
dessus allez c'est parti regardez moi
cette pente
je suis écrivain je suis nolito de
maupassant
j'écris des livres de littérature
ouais non et je me suis lancé dans més à
la base et c'était pas mais c'est je le
dis à chaque fois parce que c'est
vraiment la vérité j'ai pas commencer à
créer un livre pour écrire un livre j'ai
vraiment excité pour moi moi je disais
en story ouais j'ai écrit et j'étais en
larmes parce que moi sûrement une
madeleine donc je pleure à tout moment
et donc je j'ai dit en stores et wet
j'écris ça fait énormément du bien
j'apprends des choses sur moi mais
vraiment la base c'est un journal intime
pour moi les maisons d'édition contacter
karine de mon agence moi j'étais là mais
les gens si je ça va intéresser enfin et
en fait j'avais déjà bien écrit donc les
maisons d'édition ont pu lire un petit
bout de mes de mon livre et enfin de
montligeon mon journal intime ils m'ont
dit mais en fait c'est pas juste un truc
que tu racontes à vis un truc où tu peux
aider certaines personnes qui font des
crises angoisse ou des gens qui ne vont
pas des crises endroit second
est ce qu'ils vont pas des crises
angoisse bas ils vont peut-être au moins
comprendre enfin au moins accepter ce ne
sont pas très nombreuses mais au moins
ils vont comprendre ce qui se passe
enfin comment ça ça arrive une crise
encore j'ai plein de cailloux dans ma
crocs tout va bien j'ai plus de
chaussettes un point qui va
tu restes ici ben [ __ ] faut que je me
concentre pas mais là bas on me l'a bien
fait tu viens
qui vient qu'on va voir le père
autoritaire tu restes ici c'est bien
ça c'est ma phrase ça c'est la phrase
j'aime ça me gêne c'est la phrase qui
m'a le plus ému quand j'ai écrit ce
livre ça fait un peu le mec qui sème en
disant ça quand j écris ce gène mgmt
c'était vraiment mon père m'avait dit
j'aime ce avant d'aimer quelqu'un il
faut s'aimer soi même il m'avait 10ème
ça me gêne c'est quand il m'avait dit ça
au téléphone au début ça faisait pas
sens je comprenais pas j'étais là ouais
et en fait quand j'ai écrit ce livre est
vers la fin du livre je crois que c'est
fou au milieu mais un peu après que je
commence à alger les cris et là je me
suis mis à pleurer en écrivant cette
race je me saisis mais c'est vrai en
fait c'est ça le primordial dans une vie
c'est de s'aimer déjà à la base donc
alors j'aime ça me james james essaye de
s'aimer complètement me fasse et c'est
un long cheminement on peut pas dire que
j'aime ça me gêne c'est à 100% encore ce
serait trop
c'est très fort